By now, surely you've heard of...
"Pickelball."
"-Pickleball. "
"-Pickleball!"
Right?
The so-called...
"...fastest growing sport in the country."
Pickleball's popularity skyrocketed
during the pandemic...
bringing it out of retirement communities
and into the mainstream.
Oh, my God.
It is a phenomenon.
I discovered pickleball and a light went off in my head.
Where would you be without pickleball right now?
I honestly don't know.
Now there are fancy new
Instagram ads
selling trendy paddles and balls...
a professional league backed by
Kevin Durant and LeBron James...
and a Facebook group for pretty much
every town in America.
Everybody loves Pickleball.
Well, maybe not everybody.
"Why don't you take that pickleball
and shove it up your ******!"
"A catastrophe..."
"The lantern flies of the sports world."
So how did pickleball take over?
And where can it go from here?
It's not hard to understand
pickleball's appeal.
It's sort of like a giant adult
playground game
that's easy to pick up and
find people to play with.
Whenever we come out and
it's actually nice weather
the entire ground is covered
with pickleball courts.
I live literally like
right next door here
and I just saw scores of people
on the weekends and...
I kinda just jumped in.
The rules are similar to tennis
but played on a much smaller court.
Which means less running
and quicker games.
And pickleball can be played
anywhere.
The nets are advertised as being
portable and easy to assemble
and there's plenty of resources online
that show you how to carve up
a tennis court
into one, two, or up to four
pickleball courts.
In some places, the impromptu
nature of the sport
has caused some friction
and so-called turf wars for public space.
Like at the Peninsula Tennis Club
in San Diego
where a group of pickleball players
staged a dramatic take over
demanding its tennis courts
be converted for pickleball.
In Santa Rosa, public courts dual-lined
for pickleball and tennis
were vandalized with motor oil.
To send the message that the new craze
was no longer welcome there.
But it's not just the fight for court space
that has some people fed up
with pickleball.
This is a sound level meter.
It measures sound pressure levels in decibels.
A decibel is one unit of loudness
and it's measured logarithmically
rather than linearly.
Basically, that means that
steadily increasing sound level by 10 decibels
doesn't look like this...
but more like this
where each increase of 10 decibels
sounds twice as loud.
So a motorcycle at 100 decibels
sounds twice as loud as a hairdryer
at 90 decibels.
Which is twice as loud as a
vacuum cleaner at 80 decibels.
This is Sam.
He produces Vox Atlas and
he's going to help me
with a little experiment.
Okay, go ahead.
Bouncing a tennis ball
on a tennis racket
averaged around 70 decibels...
which is comparable to the noise level
of a busy office.
When we measured the sound of
a pickleball against a paddle...
it clocked in around 80 decibels.
That's right where sound becomes
loud enough to be irritating.
Now, obviously, this isn't the most
scientific experiment
and of course, tennis matches
make sound.
But the point is pickleball's equipment:
rigid paddles against hollow plastic balls...
makes a lot of noise.
"I wake up,
I hear it."
"I walk down the steps,
I hear it. "
[imitating clanking]
"As loud as a rock concert."
Mounting noise complaints have
forced cities and towns
from Victoria, British Columbia to
Newport, Rhode Island
to come up with temporary solutions
like limited hours for pickleball
and in some places, banning
the sport altogether.
Both sides of this conflict agree.
Pickleball has to go somewhere.
Expanding or creating dedicated space
for the sport
would help alleviate the strain
on shared spaces
and help isolate the noise issue
pickleball brings.
A wave of developers have already
cashed in on the demand
opening state of the art
private pickleball clubs
across the country.
So far, underfunded parks and
rec departments
have been moving slower
but progress is being made.
Cincinnati recently opened this free-to-the-public
pickleball facility
a collaboration in between
community fundraisers...
the Cincinnati Parks Department...
and the philanthropic Cincinnati Parks Foundation
converted 8 dilapidated tennis courts
into 18 pickleball courts,
plus 3 dual-line courts
for pickleball and tennis.
What was formerly a mostly ignored space
drew over 13,000 pickleball players
in 2022.
There's plans like this in the works
all over the country.
This one was shared with me
by the Peninsula Tennis Club.
That's where that angry pickleball
takeover took place in April 2022.
Their proposal would convert
this unused space
away from the tennis courts
for pickleball courts.
These projects need funding,
but where pickleball goes
other facilities benefit.
Efforts to invest in public
pickleball courts
are resulting in new volleyball courts...
basketball courts and
skateparks too.
But until more courts become available...
and maybe even after they do
pickleball will likely maintain
its DIY spirit.
There are pickleball courts
around the city
but we could just come in here and play
like not really plan anything in advance
and just find a spot..
Being able to just like grab a little bag here
and come out
and text my friends and have people show up
and meet new people
is very appealing I think.